eric i had an amazing oh no my queen
moment can you look at the game it's
pretty short
uh yeah
maybe i'll i'll pull a gotham chassis
and just like
and just do
game review impromptu
and uh and react
i probably won't be as dramatic but i'll
try and be somewhat instructive
i'm very happy to see
london you're playing exactly like me
uh d6
okay e3 e3 is like the old move that
it's it's very typical for london
players
uh the move i prefer after d6 is to go
for
a pierce
um so you like white would really like
to play e4 here
and the move to prepare e4 is to play
knight c3 and the reason for this is
because
if black wants to play d5 to prevent e4
it loses a tempo
and this is just a jobava london
but white has an extra tempo
um and if bishop five preventing e4
then there's a nifty move f3
and again if d5
it's jobava london up a tempo where f3
is actually a
move you play quite often to repair this
and
etc some kingside pawn storm
so
uh i see the rating here like e3 is
completely completely fine at really any
rating level but
knight c3 it's a higher level move that
i recommend trying
okay so going forward so white's doing
the normal london setup
um yeah sometimes you can mix it up play
like c4 knight c3 to be a bit more
active
but c3 yeah this pawn structure is
generally very good against
being kind of bishop like this
so
no real complaints so far
okay this is my first complaint bishop
d3 you don't want to put your bishop on
the diagonal where there's a just a very
solid pawn chain for black
in this position the bishop should
either go to c4 or to e2
more often to e2
but
yeah bishop d3 is sometimes asking for
trouble because black has this idea and
then push push
with the fork
so
[Music]
okay game continues
still playable
wow h4
playing like leela chess
h5 okay
i like knight g5 yeah it looks like
white's kind of uh setting up some king
side attack some idea to sack
i like the fact that white's delete
casting too because there might be
potential to
just castle queen side and go ham on the
king's side
thank you beluga something curry
ooh 94 yeah i would like to play f3 here
94 just seems like it's going for
unnecessary trades
oh 95
going for unnecessary declining of
trades
wow it's getting spicy the square is
just uh
an orifice in black's position
okay white has a fork bishop c4 check is
still playable
no
you should take the bishop and then fork
triple fork
more like just double fork
white's winning material here
um
yeah i've realized that at sometimes
lower levels it's easy to miss
undefended squares in the points
territory
like for higher level players it's i
think pretty straightforward to spot a
squarely e6
but
that's really really important to
address squares that are not defended in
the opponent's position that you can
exploit
so
okay going forward
was made
d5 okay yeah there's still so much
potential to do things with the knight
um meanwhite's still better
and yeah okay finally knight e6 good to
see oh
oh look at this move
oh i'm so proud
b5 and then knight fg5 oh no my queen
knight fg5 from a player rated just over
a thousand wow
was this intentional or was this
accidental
aura mirta says
the funniest part is that i didn't even
miss a fork i just tried to lock or to
look for something
better but i should have done it well
it's good that you missed the fork
because it led to
an absolutely beautiful
sequence of moves
opponent took the bait
and now check i took a course on
icelandic mythology we always wanted to
visit
oh
oh that's cool
i thought that was the beginning of a
joke i was waiting for the punchline
when you combine icelandic and mythology
i guess there's
there's a whole realm of
what are they called gnomes
isn't there like a a thing with iceland
people that like
there's gnomes or elves that live in the
country
anyway good job to oramirta
what a beautiful mate
night's doing dirty work